dr win tard ravi de vous voir vous avez
quelques heures avant votre première
consultation
bonjour me dis
qu'est-ce que tu dessines manier
j'aimerais mettre la main sur le dossier
de son ancienne clinique le mieux de
prendre un nouveau départ avec ce
patient
qu'est ce que ça représente un accident
c'était aux infos c'est moi qui les fais
tu as eu comme une vision dans ton
esprit
non dans votre tiroir
est-ce que manier aurait pu entrer dans
mon bureau avant ou après un rendez-vous
non
à l'eau
avant que vous tue
depuis que je suis arrivé ici tout
semble si est réel c'est là que les
problèmes commencent en ressassant
vous l'avez rendu réel en regardant en
ouvrant ce tiroir donc notre façon de
penser le monde ne devient elle pas de
notre monde restait en fait il doit y
avoir une explication logique à trois
avec toi
parle-moi de cette offre l'homme avec
les cheveux ébouriffés est-ce qu'il peut
être sauvé et non
envie de jouer
j'ai le contrôle à
je dessine la réalité je détruirai tout
[Musique]